- "I have a question.
"In English, why do you say chicken pox
"instead of varicella?
"In French, we say Varicelle.
"I don't understand the chicken."
(chicken squawks)
I don't understand the chicken either.
I'm digging through the comments:
Reddit, Facebook, YouTube,
even my own personal Discord server,
courtesy of my Patreon folks.
Resident Discord, Elizabeth:
"Mike, what medical specialty
"would you never want to go into?"
(drum roll)
The answer to that would be,
radiology.
It's not because I don't like radiology,
I actually think it's fun.
I just can't sit in a dark room,
without having any patient interaction.
I feed of patient interaction,
I feed of this conversation
that we're having right now.
Do you feel that energy?
(air swooshing)
(cartoon popping)
Kim Vestal: "What is the
best medical alert system
"for the elderly?"
- I can't get up.
- I think the best thing you can do
for the elderly family
members that you have,
is teach them the basics of technology.
E-mails, texting, 911,
that cellphone can be the
difference between life or death.
Stormy Sutcliff, YouTube: "Can
people develop a food allergy
"late in life and then it goes away?"
So many this does happen.
A lot of times people
package food intolerances
with food allergies.
I actually had a great dermatologist,
Dr. Dave Stukus on the
channel, talk all about that.
Now, I'm linking that video
about food allergies down below.
There's a lot of myths out
there, a lot of misinformation.
Like those blood tests,
they're not the end-all-be-all
when it comes to food allergies.
Circle Ception5: "Hey they
say no dumb questions,
it sounded like a rhyme.
"But how many individual
strands of hair do you have?"
I have no idea of the exact
number of hair strands you have.
But I can tell you that
losing up to a hundred
of them in a single day isn't a big deal.
Discord, Vasili: "Can
natural immunity wear off
"after many years of your life?
"Such as obtaining
chicken pox at a young age
"and never being vaccinated towards it?"
Yes, absolutely immunity fades
and it fades at different intervals.
This is why for example with COVID-19,
we're very careful when we make
statements about antibodies.
A, we don't know what level
of antibodies you need
to be considered immune.
And B, we don't know how long
that level of immunity will
even last, it's a new illness.
Jenishraythatha, Reddit:
"Can we remove water
"from someone's lungs by
holding them upside down
"at an angle?"
Like shaking them?
No, you've got to perform CPR.
Discord, Resident Power.
You're probably wondering, why
is he yelling resident power?
This is a private Discord
from my Patreon homies,
my residents, those who
signed up to pay $10 a month,
and all of that gets donated to charity.
And we all decide together where it goes.
We have fun, there's a lot
of behind the scenes content
that gets posted there.
We chat on a private Discord channel.
So if you want, that link is down below.
Definitely, sign up.
"Do you think it's important
to tell your doctor
"that you're gay, lesbian et cetera?"
Not only do I think it's important
for you to tell your doctor,
I think a good doctor
should ask the question.
When I talk to my patients
and I ask them if they're sexually active?
That's one question,
it's an important one.
The next follow-up question should be,
who do you prefer to have sex with?
Or who do you have sex with?
All of that faces different
risks, different challenges,
and we have to be open and ready
to have all those discussions.
Mel Veigas: "Can you take
medicines or even food
"if it's a few months
past the expiration date?"
For food, no, unless
it's a "BEST BY" date.
When it comes to medicines,
there's actually been studies by the FDA,
and by the United States military,
in looking at carefully
stored medications.
Meaning that they're not
stored in a moist environment,
they're out of direct sunlight.
They're between the temperature parameters
that you're suppose to store medicines at.
And they actually lasted
five to 10 years past
their expiration date.
That doesn't mean I'm recommending you
to take expired medicines,
especially if they are
life saving medications.
If you have insulin that is expired,
or an epipen that is expired,
both life saving medications.
Get them nude, nude, renewed.
What am I talking about?
Get them renewed.
Facebook, Chris Boles:
"Back muscle spasms.
"Why do they happen?
"Is it to compensate for
an underlying problem?
"Why does the body inflict pain on itself?
"What is the point?"
I'm gonna tell you this answer
in a very roundabout way.
You'll probably be confused at first.
When we're trying to create robots,
you may think that the
most difficult thing
for us to recreate in a robot
that is human like, is the eye.
Wrong, we've done it so many times.
The ear, wrong, we've
done it so many times.
It's walking upright.
Being able to navigate,
steps, slipping, heels,
angles, pushes, force.
All of that takes an enormous
amount of coordination.
Constant firing of neurons.
Flexing and relaxing and
extension of muscles.
When that happens, it's very
easy for a muscle to fire
either in the wrong pattern
or get thrown off balance,
and therefore creating a micro tear.
When a micro tear is
formed inside a muscle,
the muscle actually
spasms to protect itself.
The reason why massaging feels
good, why icing feels good,
because it actually allows
the muscle to get more
circulation and heal itself.
So it's not like the body
is causing it self-damage,
it's more like the outside world
causes all sorts of scary situations
that your body deals with very well.
That instead of dying,
you get a muscle spasm.
I think it's a worthy trade off.
Discord, Cheezie Weenie,
okay interesting name.
"Do people who drink less
"get drunk easier when they do drink?
"Or that does that have no effect?"
When you say get drunk easier,
I take that as, do they
look symptomatically drunk?
Are they slurring their words?
Do they seem out of control?
Are they able to walk a straight line?
Those who drink more often,
tend to have a higher tolerance
of showing their inebriation.
- This drink, I like it.
- That doesn't mean
that it's the same thing
as a blood alcohol content.
Every individual will have
their blood alcohol content
slightly different how it
goes up drink to drink.
But those who drink more
often will be able to tolerate
a higher blood alcohol content
and not show themselves being as drunk.
Hope that makes sense.
Jonathan Stern: "True or false.
"The reason it takes longer
"to catch your breath on cold days
"is because it takes your body longer
"to heat up the air you breathe in
"in order for it to be usable."
Your body does have to heat up the air,
it doesn't have to be heated up
in order for it to be usable.
There's a few factors at play.
One, air in the wintertime is drier,
so it can dry out your airways
that makes it difficult to breathe.
Breathing very cold air can
cause bronchial constriction,
where the bronchus, the airway
that leads to the lungs,
they can actually constrict
and make it difficult to breath
as if you're breathing
through a small straw
as opposed to a bigger straw.
TombWraith: "In 2013, I was
involved in a car accident
"that left me with a spinal cord injury.
"What are some good ways to
lose weight as a paraplegic?"
Good news.
70 to 80% of weight loss
comes from what you take into your body.
So make sure you are eating healthy foods
at the right amount and
staying in a healthy weight,
one that is healthy for you.
Zombs: "Question: I am 15 and 5'8,
"my mum is 5'1 and my dad is 5'10,
"what is the best way I
can maximize my height
"and what is your best prediction
on how tall I will be?"
My prediction for how tall you
will be is gonna be useless
because I have no idea.
(crowd applauding)
My dad is 5'9, my mom was 5'9, I'm 6'3.
I can't tell you how you
could maximize your height.
Get enough sleep.
When you undersleep,
you actually undercut your
secretion of growth hormone.
Growth hormone is massively important
to your height and your bone growth.
Get the right amount of sleep,
make sure you are getting
all the nutrients,
and challenge your body physically.
Because when you exercise well,
you'll also have an improvement
in your hormonal profile,
thereby, potentially getting taller.
Discord, Dina Zwitscher:
"What is your favorite organ?
"(PG Version)."
My favorite organ is probably,
(clock ticking)
I like the stomach.
Not only is it cool
enough that it can pivot,
meaning it can expand and shrink
depending on how much food you take in.
It's very muscular and
strong, it can beat up food,
it has rugae in it, so it's all lined
and it can handle acid, so its tough.
And I like to eat, so stomach.
Jason Roberge: "On a previous video,
"you covered if cracking your
knuckles was bad for you.
"How about other locations,
like your neck, or back?"
Same principal really applies.
Every time you hear a
crack, (bones cracking).
I won't be able... (bones cracking).
But any time you crack your back or neck,
it's just nitrogen, air
bubbles in your joints popping.
If you're doing it
because there's something
unhealthy in your joints
or your posture, that itself is unhealthy.
Get ready to see some creepy crawlers
and an upside down airplane
with me flying it, what?
Click on them.
And as always, stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)